time to open up the mailbag first
question our good friend a red zone out
because richard sherman
short on offers for next year he seems
to be begging the 49ers to keep him now
obviously he can't negotiate with anyone
until the offseason but it is weird that
he keeps making it known
that he won't be back with the 40s 49ers
next year for financial reasons it's not
like he's playing
at the same level he was at last year
one of the reasons is they don't have
the pass rush which exposes him a little
bit more
every time i pay attention to him it
just looks like a lot of standing around
to me frankly shireen
i don't know if anyone's going to give
him big money it would have been better
for him to hit the market coming off of
his 2019 season
than 2020 maybe he has to move to safety
i don't know but but i don't expect
anyone
to give him a huge offer for 2021
i don't know that that means he goes
back to the 49ers eventually
but i am kind of surprised by this
this presumption by richard sherman that
he's going to get a giant pile of money
as a free agent this year yeah
and especially with the salary cap going
down like we expected to go down mike
there's no way he's getting big money
and he's his own agent obviously and
you've made a big point
of that he negotiates his own contracts
the the 49ers i was amazed by this they
they have 40 guys scheduled to become
free agent that's unbelievable to me and
they want to resign trent williams and
fred warner among the guys they want to
keep
so yeah they're probably not going to be
able to afford richard sherman
but i i'm like you i don't know where he
thinks he's going to go to get
big money because i just don't see any
team paying him
big money when you have a lot of
contracts to redo there's a lot of free
agents on the market who are better than
richard sherman
guys are going to draft and the
sauerkraut's going down it just doesn't
make sense to me that anybody's going to
give him big money i expect a one-year
deal that's
reasonable i i don't know where i saw
this and i don't know if this was on the
pft writer's text chain but the idea
that maybe he would go back
to seattle if they could mend fences
appropriately i don't know that they can
but he needs to be in a system where he
fits he needs to be in a system where
he's not expected to cover guys down
the field because he just can't i'm not
sure that he ever
could but he definitely can't at this
point and that's just one of the
realities so
maybe it's richard sherman the agent
being as shrewd as he can be for richard
sherman the player but
i don't see it all it takes is one team
to offer him too much money and then
mission accomplished but he would have
been in a better
spot for that last year than this year
next question skull vikings 407 are we
giving taysom hill too much credit for
the saints success
because the defense has been spectacular
shireen
i think we're not giving the saints
defense enough credit i
i would rephrase the question a little
bit i mean they're first in total
defense but they're not a team that
quickly comes to mind when you start
thinking about the great defenses in
this league this year you think the rams
you think of the steelers maybe you
think of the bucks although they've
gone down a little bit since then but
the saints don't come immediately to
mind
but you think about the job that aggie
great dennis allen's done
in rebuilding this defense and they've
given him a lot of parts i realize they
give him a lot of first round draft
picks they've done a lot to rebuild the
defense
but when he got there in 2015 they
ranked 32nd
2015 31st in 2016 and points allowed
and now they're doing what they're doing
this year it's just been amazing to me
that they've managed to turn that around
and i think dennis allen probably
deserves mike a second chance as a head
coach
you can't really
have anybody judged by what they do with
the raiders
based on them being the raiders i think
he deserves another chance to be a head
coach because i think he can be a very
good head coach in this league
it's amazing how certain guys become
darlings of the media and you hear
specific names raised all the time
dennis allen's name
never comes up maybe he needs a better
agent maybe he needs better friends in
the media
it really is a significant part of the
game
the people in the media who will tout
you but maybe dennis allen
should be touted more than he is so
somebody's not working the dennis allen
angle
the way that they should because this is
a team
with an offensive minded head coach who
as he explained to me earlier this week
when we talked about the jets end of
game debacle
the head coach is involved the head
coach is monitoring the head coach is
checking that
there isn't going to be a zero blitz
with the game on the line but still
it's dennis allen's defense dennis allen
is in charge of it and he's done a great
job with it and i think somebody needs
to
you know we're not here to advocate for
anyone it's up to the teams you you make
your decision you make your bet whether
it's good or whether it's bad
but it is odd to me that some guys get
touted and some guys don't
back to taysom hill it's not odd to me
that he's getting credit
he's playing well he's improving as a
passer he has more time to work with the
receivers when you're the backup
quarterback
you don't get to work with the starting
receivers the starting quarterback does
so now that he's done it for three weeks
he's getting his timing down that's what
he told me after
the win over the falcons the idea that
that he
spends time after practice working on
that timing
making it easier for the receivers to
catch the ball and so uh he
everyone should be getting more credit
in new orleans including sean payton for
putting it all together all right one
more question
tweets by donovan wants to know what
would be a bigger story the chiefs
losing
to the dolphins or the dolphins beating
the chiefs
i i think it'd be the dolphins being the
chief simply because they
to me they have two really good wins in
the cardinals and the rams but those
were both
nfc teams they won't come into play in
the playoffs if they beat the chiefs
then i think we're talking about the
dolphins potentially being a hard
out in the postseason in the afc
yeah i agree with you and also also what
it does
it if the chiefs would lose
and the bills beat the steelers it it
makes that top seed
very intriguing down the stretch and
unfortunately for the bills they lost to
the chief so it's not like they could
they could sweep in with a tiebreaker
but uh if the if the bills look really
good against the steelers on sunday and
if the chiefs would lose
with three games left you'd have to
wonder is there a way the bills can pull
the inside straight and end up getting
the buy shireen
yeah absolutely and that buy is going to
be significant this year we know only
one team gets it
it's going to be probably between the
chiefs and the steelers but some tough
games for both of these games down the
stretch
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports